for more on an eventful 24 hours in the
capital they all seem eventful now we
turn to Phillip bump national
correspondent for the Washington Post
Phillip good morning morning sir let's
talk about the most recent news which
literally happened while we SMO STUV us
lat maybe you were sleeping but this is
a major legislative win for the
president and something he's are looking
for but it's not law yet where does
where does it go from here that's
exactly right so the house has passed a
version of the tax cuts already that
that passed basically was not noticed
because the houses has a much stronger
Republican majority the Senate bill now
has it has a different set of changes to
tax law and so essentially they now go
into something called conference where
the house in the Senate try and work
together and figure out one unified
package that everyone can agree to the
vane has to go back to both chambers for
another vote so this is not over yet but
this is a much further along process
than was the health care bill for
example which we all know failed in the
Senate earlier this year so this is
significant for the Republicans in that
sense it's significant also insofar as
it bucks a decade of Republican
orthodoxy about not adding to the
federal deficit right fill up by the
most rosy estimates this is gonna cost
at least a trillion dollars that's
exactly right so there's a group called
the Joint Committee on taxation which is
actually a congressional nonpartisan
group which assessed this bill and even
incorporating economic estimates for how
they economy will grow you're right this
would be a 1 trillion dollar hit on the
deficit this is something however that
Republicans have they have largely
dismissed Mitch McConnell yesterday
saying Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell saying this that essentially
this will pay for itself there would be
enough growth there are very few
economist who actually think that will
happen so this is a stark change the
Democrats complained loudly about that
they didn't have time to read the
amendments in this bill and that some of
them arrived and written with words you
couldn't even understand we saw Jon
Tester there but does this set a
precedent in terms of how bills you know
are drafted and passed we'll see if it
sets a precedent mean it's sort of hard
to predict but this is certainly
something that the Republicans have
learned is a way to among other things
avoid a lot of public outcry right I
mean we saw that the health care bill
for example was drafted very quickly
they try to move it very quickly and in
part that was to avoid the sort of
organized activity by grassroots
Americans coming out and saying that
they they object to it now the
this has to go back to conference has to
go back to the House and the Senate
there is more time for people to learn
what's in this to actually raise any
objections or support if they if they
choose to do so but it was clear that
part of that that's that speed was meant
to try and offset objections we talked
about this as a tax bill but it's also a
health bill Philip it is gonna repeal
Obamacare individual mandate which is
crucial to the survival of the
marketplaces what are the implications
for the broad sectors of American
economy that are touched by this I mean
there are huge implications it's it's a
totally important point and in to some
extent we don't even know what all the
implications are in part because the
bill was sort of cobbled together
yesterday and has a lot of potential
loopholes and a lot of potential
implications but the healthcare point is
is a totally important one this is
almost certainly going to lead to more
people who are dropping out of health
care and coverage will mean more people
who end up declaring bankruptcy because
they don't have health care coverage the
Congressional Budget Office actually
looked at this and because of the repeal
of an individual mandate there is
essentially the federal government will
be making money off of people who make
less than something like $40,000 a year
even despite the tax cuts because I'll
be saving money I'm not having to help
subsidize their health insurance so this
is you know in that regard then this is
even more beneficial to the wealthy and
less beneficial to poor Americans
because of that change of the individual
mandate at the same time Philip that the
President had what certainly his biggest
legislative victory all of this is being
overshadowed by of course the Flint
situation what do we think the White
House is feeling right now because their
initial reaction was this is not a big
deal right well I mean if you look at
what Donald Trump has said at every
point along the way he said this is not
a big deal even after the meeting
between Donald Trump jr. and a russian
lawyer emerged last year so that's sort
of the White House's standard line but
this is a big deal right I mean that
Michael Flynn was charged with only one
small thing suggest that he is working
with Robert Mahler's team he is prepared
to give testimony and robert muller is
not gonna make a deal with him to give
up some low ranking member of the Trump
staff this is there's clearly some
bigger fish that they're looking at here
and we know that there are sealed
indictments as well that may include
other people who may be working with
Robert Muller's team there's a lot of
nebula sness we don't know all the
answers here yet but it's
Moeller it has his eyes on something big
right the significance of Flynn's
information may be equally diametrically
opposed to the the the sort of small
size of the charge exactly bunk from The
Washington Post thanks Philip